chris is with us in Sioux Falls hi Chris
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show thank
you Dave how are you better than I
deserve how can I help
well I could really use some quality
advice I'm really really struggling
right now and I'm faced with some very
very difficult decisions and I'm trying
to come to terms with how that might
affect how I spend all any time with my
kids I have been separated from my
marriage for four years divorced about
three I have my kids every other week
and I just recently went through my
second job loss in two years I've been
unemployed for the last two months the
last time I was unemployed I went
through about nine months of
unemployment and the funds are really
really low but that's a piling up and I
just really don't know what to do
I've been listening to a lot of your
podcasts and the one thing well one of
those many great things that I've been
hearing but one of the regular things
that I hear is you just work work work
and I'm not afraid of work I just want
to make sure that you know my kids are
nine and fourteen I want to make sure
that I can have some quality time with
them and I don't actually you're going
to have to work you're to work to be
able to do that right I get that you
know and so there's gonna be stairs
listen all dads and moms have trade offs
we have to produce economically to
provide for our family and that means
sometimes we miss a recital well and I I
certainly understand this in a recital
but you know if I'm picking up you know
second shifts or third shifts here and
there or maybe that's my regular job you
know how and my kids are in school how
am i spending time with them if I'm
household income well I'm not positive
on the short term on the short term you
figure it out on the long term you
change that around I would not prescribe
that you work something where you never
see your children ever for 10 years but
you may have to do that for five months
because you're broke and unemployed it
may be a very difficult five months but
if you wallow around and III can't do
anything to create money because I have
to have time for my kids you're gonna
struggle from now on what were you doing
before what kind of job are you were you
doing before I was a project manager in
the medical industry long term health
care industry in making what kind of
money the one you just got fired from oh
the last one that I just got fired from
was was not that was in was in a
technology field I was making between 50
and 55 doing what and technology a lot
of electronic data interchange data
passing between insurance companies and
health care providers okay all right
Kent can you take those that was not my
industry okay all right but your
industry's project managing yeah yeah
okay now why did you lose this job
it was part of a large corporate layoff
oh it laid off about 10-15 percent of
their staff well one thing you can do is
come up with a self-employed idea where
you take some of your project management
skills or your tech skills and you start
doing those as an outsource for small
business and then you can control your
time as you work when you want to work
and when you know when the customer
needs you but you're going to work when
you want to work you can at least you
can you know you're not locked into a
set schedule that way but you
desperately need to do something to
create income around there on a regular
basis anything
[Music]